Hey guys, Trace here for Dnews.
And you're on the internet right now, right?
So you may be familiar with the vices of human
life and we've put together a playlist of
substances, both legal and illegal, that surrounds
us everyday.
So if you're interested in how a cop might
be able to tell if you're high, or if you
want to know the science behind the placebo
effect, or maybe how magic mushrooms might
be treating depression, then this is the playlist
for you.
And you should click on the little floating
box somewhere in front of me here, or look
in the description for the link.
And hey, if you like the vids, make sure you
subscribe to Dnews so you don't miss any our
future explorations into the back-alley parts
of the human experience.
See you later.